I love it when you ask for a manager  because then I don't have to talk to you  anymore  [Music]  this isn't my real voice I'm making  myself sound much more pleasant than I  really am thank you for calling CCS  enterprises your estimated wait time is  due  [Music]  [Music]  this is the one place in this building  where I'm allowed to be alone with my  thoughts  [Music]  [Music]  I'm just calling because you responded  positively to Stanley  [Music]  [Music]  I've gotten so good at speaking with  confidence that I don't know if any of  this information is true  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  I've been new people while he talked so  I can either swear at you or eat food  [Music]  [Music]  I love captivating things and this must  really be captivate cause it keeps me  off the phones  [Music]  [Music]